[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life your money
your mental wellness
your relationships your boundaries your
career your job we talk about you right
here in front of you it's called the
ramsay show open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five the
call is free and some say the advice is
worth exactly what you pay for it we're
going to start with gene in denver hey
gene welcome to the ramsay show
just retired from my job i'm collecting
a pension of about 5 300
but it has a condition where i could
take less 25 less and keep that for my
wife should i pass and that would be
about 3 900. and the advice of called
take out universal life policy with a
long-term care writer to save that
thirteen hundred dollars to pay for the
insurance
uh do you think that's why i've got a
paid for house
i don't have any debt i'm debt-free then
i've got about 750 000 in my savings ira
i missed you you kind of cut out when
you said where that horrible advice came
from
from my financial advisors oh you need a
new one you have an insurance salesman
right yeah um he's not a he's not a
financial advisor he's an insurance
salesman because he's selling his whole
life no one else sells that crap except
people that are in the insurance
business
so now i if you want to buy some
insurance what's your net worth
uh it's 1.1 million
okay and how much of that is the house
about 400 000. okay so you got 700 000
in investments
roughly
it all depends what my house would go
for
he said that i could invest in the whole
life so that it would be tax-free to
convert my 401k into factory should i
die
it would
convert your 401k into what
into a life uh universal whole life
uh well that's what if i die yeah that's
true because you lose all the money
so usually when you lose all your money
it's tax-free so no you need to get away
from this guy he's horrible
uh his advice is horrible
uh no you need to keep your investments
in real investments and then when you
die your wife will get the investments
and if you want to supplement the level
of net worth that you have it should you
die
you can do that with some term life
insurance for a short period of time how
old are you
i'm 15.
58 okay so when you're 65
you're going to have 1.4 million dollars
in investments assuming your money is
invested in decent growth stock mutual
funds
yes it'll double about every seven years
when you're 72
you'll have
uh
2.8 almost 3 million dollars in
investments how's your health
my house is good good okay how old is
your wife
she's two years older than me she'll be
60 in a couple months okay so what we're
doing is we're saying if your pension
disappears
right because you died
what does your wife need that your net
worth does not now provide
and so seven hundred thousand would
create maybe sixty or seventy thousand
dollars worth of income
um if something happened to you what's
your income today
i'm retired i'm just i'm just collecting
my pension of uh thirty and about four
thousand dollars okay this time to four
thousand and that's why i could take the
whole thing at 53
but if i die
she would give nothing yep and we're
both in good health it's just a matter
of playing the odds yep i'm taking the
53
and if you want to play it if you want
to play a math game you invest the
difference in that in 3 900
and you buy term life insurance out of
some of that difference and you will
come out with a lot more than this goob
is offering you with this horrible
policy
um yeah i'm a long-term care writer i
wouldn't need it no you don't need a
long-term care writer
if you want if you don't tie long-term
care into life insurance it's a gimmick
and they overcharge for it if you need
long-term care just go to an insurance
broker and get long-term care insurance
right okay i figured i would have enough
with with my
my retirement so here's the thing if you
go into a nursing home are you going to
burn through this nist egg and leave her
with nothing if the answer is yes you
need long-term care insurance
if the or leave her with not enough
so
since you're concerned about it i might
buy a half million dollars in um
life insurance term life insurance for
five years or 10 years
something like that is if you're getting
good health it's not going to be that
expensive
and at 60 i would buy some long-term
care insurance but in the meantime i'm
not
here's a good rule here's a good rule
here's a good rule
never
use
a life insurance policy as an investment
vehicle
100
of those suck
mathematically
100 percent it's kind of like saying
never do payday lending ken it's like
saying never there is never a case where
leasing a car makes sense that's right
there is never a case where going into
debt at 18 interest on a credit card
makes sense there's not one
you're not the exception snowflake these
are all stupid things they go in one
bucket the stupid bucket and just never
never never never do that so thank you
for calling i'm glad you called
hopefully i helped you avoid a hundreds
of thousands of dollars mistake here i
would keep the full pension and if you
want to buy a little bit of term and
later on buy some long-term care
insurance that's what i would do as
separate policies never bundled
yeah i think what you laid out for him
is actually alleviating all of his
concerns and they're not bad financial
decisions he's healthy at 58. you said
seven years from now he's gonna double
so if he gets it to 65 i mean he's got
everything taken care of and they're in
good financial shape i think they're
clearly living below their means anyway
oh they've done a great job
a millionaire yeah so here's the thing
on both of those insurance policies
insurance is what you buy for one reason
only
to cover something you can't cover
yourself
so if you're broke
stone cold broke and you have a five
thousand dollar car
you need to cover carry insurance on
that five thousand dollar car collision
because that car being total is a
catastrophic financial event because
you're broke
if you've got 350 000 cash in your
checking account
and you're driving a 20 000 car and you
don't want to carry collision
you can afford to write the check to
replace a stupid car
so that's a that's an event you can
choose to insure or not to insure
so with your case here's the thing
long-term care insurance is this the
average nursing home care stay is 2.3
years average cost right now is about 95
000 a year so we're talking about
somewhere around 250 000.
so if you have 4 million
you don't need long-term care insurance
on average you're going to go through
250 000 for your care mama's going to be
just fine
when you die
financially speaking i'm sure she'll cry
but financially speaking
my wife is actually planning my death
and it's got me very concerned
i just need to say that out loud in
front of her oh sharon loves dave we've
been we've been married almost 40 years
and all of my estate plan is predicating
on me predeceasing her and i don't know
how she knows that so that that's
bothersome
but the uh so yeah the same thing with
long-term care the other thing is so in
his case if he wanted to if she's okay
with 700 000 yes to cover nursing home
and or cover death
human loss of income they don't need any
insurance correct if she's okay with
that i think they might be a little slim
emotionally i'd probably beef it up
because it didn't cost that much i would
for a short period of time this is the
ramsey chef
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host thank you for joining us america
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five chris is in
springfield missouri hey chris welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave this is a honor to be on the
show here well thank you how can we help
i got i i want to know your opinion on
okay
i bought at my first house last summer
me and a couple friends renovated it
according to my realtor
we increased the value by about 50 grand
and i have
some aspirations to become a small time
landlord
i was wondering if it's a totally dumb
idea
to
get a heloc on my current house
for a down payment for a second house
and turn the first one into an airbnb or
a rental yeah
chris how old are you
26. good for you cool and what do you do
for a living
i'm a plumber good okay so when you say
we did this renovation do we own the
house or you own the house and your
friends help you with renovation
i own the house and they helped yes so
it's completely in your name
yes and the house is worth how much
roughly
160 after the fact
and so you think you could sell it for
um
160 and you owe like 110.
i have about 100 grand about 100 okay so
you got about 60 equity minus expenses
all right cool
all right
yeah well in fairness as i answer the
question
when i was
to tell you who's answering the question
when i was uh
23
24 years old i started buying and
selling real estate
using the nothing down
real estate techniques
that were promising back 35 years ago
they're the same ones that are out there
floating around today telling you to buy
real estate and get rich in real estate
and so i didn't have any money i started
buying real estate i started borrowing
all the money to buy all the real estate
um i got rich
by the time i was your age at 26 i had
four million dollars worth of real
estate starting from nothing
and i had over a million dollar net
worth
uh the problem was i had no idea
the influence of debt on that situation
and i was flipping houses that's what i
was doing was fixing them and flipping
them
um i actually hired crews to do it i
know how to swing a hammer but i was
choosing to do more volume than my
hammer would do by itself and so i just
would set up a crew or hire a painter or
hire a plumber or whatever to get the
different rehab things done on the
houses i was fixing and flipping some of
them i was holding as rentals and so i
tell you all of that to tell you i
aspired
at that time to do what you aspire to do
now it's what i wanted to be is what you
want to be fair enough
yes
what happened was the bank got sold that
i was dealing with to another bank
and they looked over and saw that they
they felt like this 26 year old kid owed
them too much money and they called our
notes and we spent the next two and a
half years of our life fighting through
severe banking technicalities that i
didn't even know existed
and losing everything that we owned
we were sued we were foreclosed on and
finally we were bankrupt
at the bottom of that i started studying
how money works
and i started talking to old rich people
i didn't want to talk to young rich
people i had been him i didn't want his
advice it didn't work
and old rich people started telling me
this thing called common sense and as a
christian i started studying the bible
and it talks negatively about debt 100
of the time
and so i figured out that this debt
thing didn't work and i started buying
my i bought my first piece of real
estate after that with cash it took me a
little while
because it's hard to get the cash
together
and you made some quick you made some
quick easy money plus or minus your
sweat in this house
but it's been fairly quick and it feels
like you could do it all the time well i
did it a lot
i did it a lot
but it still came crashing down around
my ears so that's the guy you're talking
to
he not only wanted to do what you're
talking about but he did it
and i did it with debt and it backfired
on me and it wasn't that i was stupid it
was that debt is stupid
and so all of that to answer your
question and say no
i would not borrow on a heloc to go buy
a rental
i would keep working like a crazy man as
a plumber i get this house paid off if
you're gonna live in it
um
or i would sell it and take fifty
thousand sixty thousand and buy a tiny
little cheap something and flip it
with cash
and if you wanna do some flips with cash
i'm in i'm fine with that especially
where you're swinging a hammer and some
of your buddies are doing the renovation
with you and that kind of stuff that's
all cool but i'll tell you now i own
that was 35 years ago that we crashed 30
years ago that we crashed 35 years ago
that's
story started
and uh today i own several hundred
million dollars in real estate the
building i'm sitting in is worth a
hundred million
and so uh and it's all paid for 100 i do
not borrow money for anything ever
after that experience so
i tell you a big long story to give you
a really solid no don't do that
yeah you know i love the point you make
he's a young guy and if he's not living
in that house
flip that
and and get your apartment yes sir i
don't mind you renting and flipping sir
but pay cash that's right okay he's off
to a good start there if he flips that
now yeah and it's good time to make a
little money if you can get in one of
the deal very difficult to find a deal
right now yeah
like i'm almost impossible needle now i
was shocked at how how much that house
cost yeah but um but you can do that and
it's possible in springfield missouri i
mean that's a it's a great market and i
i want you to go live your dream i don't
want you to let it turn into a nightmare
and it has for me oh and by the way
there was a whole bunch of people did
nothing down real estate then i was
actually in a nothing down real estate
club
back then chris that had 150 members
let me tell you how many of those guys
are still doing real estate deals with
nothing down
zero let me tell you how many of those
guys went broke
all of us
all of us
all of us went broke
no one made it out using that technique
now i do know one guy started selling
the properties off taking the equities
and paying off the others he ended up
with a portfolio about one-third the
size of his original portfolio
downgraded by 70
but turned out with cash he went the
other way from the nothing down to 100
debt-free and he's still managing those
properties i ran into him the other day
but the guys that persisted with this
nothing down bullcrap stuff that's sold
in these weekend seminars
100 failure rate a decade later two
decades later so i want to stay there
dave because it's still being sold and
it's being glamorized on social media oh
big time so what's what are they not
telling them they they're telling you oh
you can do all this but there's
something they're not telling they're
not properly portraying the risk
what's the what's the hidden information
they're not sharing the the nothing down
deal only works if everything goes
perfect and nothing ever goes perfect
that's it
risk
debt equals risk more debt equals more
risk
if you owe a hundred thousand dollars on
on something that's a lot more risk than
if you owe 1 000 on that thing
so more debt equals more risk 100 of
time because you got to carry it if it
doesn't sell you got to carry it if the
fed decides to jack up rates oh wait
that happened you got to carry it if
there's a pandemic oh wait that happened
you got to carry it even if you lose
your job because of the pandemic oh you
got to carry it even if there's hyper
inflation so it freezes the market like
a deer in the headlights oh these are
real freaking things that happen and
they happen to me you got to carry it if
the president changes the tax
legislation and change it and flips all
investment property on its head ronald
reagan completely destroyed the real
estate market while i was in the middle
of it i'm a ronald reagan fan but worst
presidential decision he made completely
undid the investment real estate market
by flipping the
uh
flipping the uh depreciation schedules
off
changing the value of real estate with
one stroke of the pin
and it turned it turned the snl business
on its head back then the savings and
loan industry
and you can't control that crap because
you're not the president
and it it affects
things out of your control come in and
and
make you stupid when it's stress tested
always reveals itself to be stupid you
can tell it was skinny dipping when the
tide goes out oh that's what they don't
know
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free homeownership and churchill is
here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america one of
the most important types of insurance
you have is of course car insurance
it's actually the law
maybe even motorcycle insurance if
that's your thing most americans don't
have enough car insurance
and you're probably one of them if you
get into an accident you don't have
enough insurance you'll have to pay for
your own car repairs medical bills the
other drivers car repairs and their
medical bills and their passengers
medical bills it can cost you thousands
and thousands of dollars
even get you sued
you've got to have the right car
insurance and that's why we created a
network of endorsed local providers or
elps they're licensed independent
insurance agents
which means they will shop around and
get you the best deal among a bunch of
different companies
and get you the coverage that you
actually need hello they'll teach you
how to understand your car insurance a
lot of people pay for car insurance just
mad about it don't even know what they
got
you need to actually understand what
your freaking money is going to
yeah if you're ready to work with an
insurance agent who actually works for
you
not for the insurance company
visit ramseysolutions.com
auto to connect with the ramsey trusted
elp ramsey solutions.com
auto eduardo is with us in los angeles
hey eduardo what's up
hi thank you guys for taking my call
sure how can we help
yeah my question is to ken today i um
it's about a career advice i am
looking into getting into college
um
and so i am pretty clear on what i want
to study
and i always hear him talk about the
bethel tech school of technology um and
i just need some advice if you know
since college right now is
starting to become more irrelevant for a
degree
and so i don't know
so what direction do you want to go you
said you knew what you want to study
presumably you know why you want to
study that where do you want to go i
want i want to get into engineering
software engineering computer science
space yeah
well specifically what would that look
like your first entry level uh what's
that going to look like you know the
industry well enough to know what
entry-level work is going to be
um
mostly it's the coding
gotcha and
yeah so here's the answer uh computer
science degrees or many computer degrees
uh they're never going to roi for you uh
based on the fact that you want to go
into developing and coding
you don't need to do that bethel tech
obviously they are a big time partner of
the ken coleman show in fact we just got
an email this last week
the first ken coleman show grad to get a
job making over a hundred grand just
happened um and he is a recent graduate
of their nine week program that's one
example there are a lot of other coding
boot camps you need to do your homework
on reputable boot camps you know call
bethel tech but talk to other folks do
your homework because the reality is
uh to get a four-year degree and in some
places that could be as much as
thousand dollars
for some computer science degrees it
just does not roi you do not need it
google has announced a major initiative
where they are training future
developers future engineers because they
know that they can teach people what
they
need to be able to work for google and
so
it does not require a college degree not
to go the direction you want to go and
so
less time less money is what you're
looking for here and so don't feel the
trap that i have to go to college to
become a developer yeah um eduardo we've
got at ramsey solutions we have software
engineers
dev ones twos threes uh we've got
architect and platform people uh all in
the space that you're talking about
totals over 400 folks working on my team
i pay millions and millions of dollars a
year in salary and income to people like
you want to be and i would i'll just
tell you 100
we do not require a four-year degree to
enter that field
100
if you were going to hire you do code to
be a software engineer
to to write java to write ruby whatever
it is you're going to write
all we want to know is can you do it
and we're going to run a code test on
you and if you can code we're going to
bring you in and the level you code at
is the level we're going to pay you at
not what you think you are whether you
think you're a dev one or you think
you're a dev too our guys we've got you
know professional executive leadership
in this area that hire people every day
i will hire probably 60 or 70 people in
the coming 12 months in the field you're
talking about and we will not require a
four-year degree from a single
one of them
all we want to know is can you code all
we know want to know is the background
that if you have any if you have any
experience that proves you can code
if you can pass the test showing you can
code if you have the certifications from
something like bethel tech or microsoft
or whoever showing you know how to run
the technology then you're in
technology is not driven by that the
only time you would get a four year
information systems or computer science
degree is if you're going to want to go
into a very high level of leadership
where the actual coding doesn't matter
because by the time you get a four years
if you're graduating today with a
four-year degree the stuff you have
studied in college is already obsolete
because it changes
almost by the minute yeah
what they need to study uh and so being
in the field having your hands in the
code makes you much more valuable oh and
by the way it's four years of income
making a hundred thousand dollars that
you're missing out on too yeah not only
are you going to pay somebody 180 grand
so this is a five or six hundred
thousand dollar conversation we're
having right here yeah and listen i
believe in four-year degrees
if you if you ask me if you need to go
get a four-year degree in marketing i
would say yeah our four-year degree in
business or accounting i'd say yeah go
do it i think it's worth it there's
going to be some superfluous classes in
there but it's worth it you'll get an
roi on that it makes sense it's it
you know and it's going to give you
literal lift uh but i got to tell you
you come in here to interview you got a
four-year degree in information systems
or you got three years of code
experience as a software engineer i'll
take the code experience over the
four-year degree 100 of the time now i
think we're going to interview the rest
of the person and learn about them too
we're not going to rule out the guy with
a four-year degree right we're not
calling you an idiot for having one but
i'm just saying it does not even give
you a one-up no and and let me also give
an alternate path for leadership in this
space too because i've seen it happen
here at ramsey solutions it's happening
all the time where we'll have somebody
come in uh as a coder and they do great
work we realize they've got great people
skills or otherwise known as soft skills
you hear this in the marketplace all the
time and and they because they follow
well they get the opportunity to lead
and so you could you could go to a boot
camp a bethel tech like this get in do a
good job listen to the entree leadership
podcast buy the entree leadership
best-selling book written by day how do
we lead how do we teach leadership here
at ramsey solutions and begin to follow
well and work your way up the leadership
ladder as well it is possible so the
long the short is eduardo go to code
school don't go to don't go to college
not for this particular path not for
this path yeah doctor yes i wouldn't if
you were my son i would tell you no
and so and then when you graduate from
code school take a dev one position and
keep going to coach this is the key it's
a very important point just because you
come out with this that this quality
you're not going to have three when
you're getting out of school take the
entry level position the young man i was
talking about dave he was in a
non-technical technology position making
sixty thousand dollars he just got a
hundred thousand dollar entry-level
position as a dev one death cult code
school on only under his belt with a
nine week program at bethel tech which
by the way ramsey solutions because we
pay cash our audience you're going to
get it for less than 15 grand yeah so
that's not an ad for them you could go
anywhere
well i tell people check everybody out
you choose them they're great we
wouldn't endorse them if we didn't think
they were great but it's everywhere but
you know our guys all the time i mean we
even talked about opening a code school
yeah just because our need is so high
and really that's all they need to know
how to do to get in to get their foot in
the door and then they can grow from
there and we can teach them the rest
on the job in an apprenticeship type
situation because our dev3s coach our
dev ones every day they write code
together oh yeah and they'll pull them
up and teach them and so that's that's
how you learn this particular thing it's
it's like a modern day version of a
trade like welding or pipe fitting
and i'll tell you this dave the industry
the data is out there on this if you are
one of these you know brilliant
developers and you've got good people
skills there's no stopping you yeah
because
most developers don't they say it point
blank no they don't have people skills
that's not what they do most of them are
you know
game on with the with the ones and zeros
that's it yeah yeah so it's a great
space though dude and i got a bunch of
them on the team and we love them we
love them they're great people and uh
they care very deeply about their work
they're
wonderful we
it's a great interaction we have here at
ramsey with them this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host this is the ramsey show jacob is
with us in seattle hi jacob how are you
[Music]
i'm doing well dave penn thanks for
taking my call i appreciate it sure
what's up
all right so um me and my wife uh are
currently have no debt uh looking to
purchase a house in the upcoming
couple years we have a little bit of a
disagreement on how we are going to be
saving the money um i'm
i have a higher risk appetite than she
does i would like to put it into
like a diversified etfs and try to get a
little try to get the money to work for
us for
the upcoming few years before we
purchase and she would like to put it
into a high yield savings account so we
know exactly where we're going to be in
three years
how would you suggest to go about
finding a compromise with that
well i think what you both need to
realize is that this decision is not
going to keep you from buying a house
or cause you to be able to buy a house
so let's do the math for a second i'll
show you what i'm talking about
how much are you talking about saving
we would like i would like to purchase a
house that we're going to be in for the
next 30 40 basically our lifetime so
good luck with that but yeah it usually
doesn't work that way but but how much
are you talking about saving in the next
three years
uh about 200 000. okay
and so if you make 10
on this money you're going to make 20
000 bucks
if you put it in a high yield savings
you're gonna make nothing
and you'll lose twenty thousand bucks
but two hundred thousand is what's going
to cause you to build buy the house
and 220 is not going to cause you to buy
a substantially different house
so the fact that you made a little money
on your money is more of an intellectual
exercise
than a factual change in your situation
okay that makes sense i'm telling you
okay and so
uh and the same thing's true with her
let's say you put it into an etf and it
did not make 10 a year
you had a bad three year run in the
stock market stock market in general was
down you got tagged
you know in the face with this thing
which could happen in a three-year swing
and uh you don't have 200 000 you end up
with 180 000.
so you actually lost money you follow me
still doesn't keep you from buying a
house
so my point is your concern that you're
not making a bunch of money is somewhat
mathematically invalid her concern that
you're going to lose so much that
you're going to not be able to get a
house is also
not really mathematically valid this is
all more about emotion than it is actual
dollars
okay yeah that makes sense i'm following
you yeah so anyway all that to say
how do we solve this
uh
probably at our house
uh we'd probably end up splitting the
baby we'd probably get let me do uh put
a hundred thousand over in investments
and she'd put a hundred thousand over
there and at the end we would see who
won the bet
so you would say put it do a 50 50 down
the middle yeah yeah i don't think
there's anything wrong with that at all
because but again
before you do this both of you need to
really own the fact that this is not
going to cause you to buy a house or not
buy a house
it's just more of an argument over how
we spark the money
so i i gotta weigh in here
you know look i i think you do exactly
what dave just laid out walk her through
that
both sides of the coin then i would see
how she's reacting to that and if her
safety
gland is still flaring
i'm going with mama you know what i'm
happy wife happy life what's the other
alternative that's the other alternative
yeah you don't lose on that one
because if you win if you put it all in
there and you go down 30 grand i told
you that's gonna cost you 30 years yeah
of remembering that yeah
that's the truth and maybe some jewelry
it costs you a thousand dollars a year
in memory that's my remember back in on
23 when you didn't do what i said do i
remember they have memories oh oh they
are members elephants have nothing on
women yeah this is true they remember
ever
especially when they're right
that's even more devastating which again
if you want to just most of the time
that's what you need to come to that
conclusion as well so this is not even a
mathematical question find a virtuous
wife for her worth is far above rubies
the heart of her husband safely trusts
her
and he will have no lack of gain so at
our house we probably today we would
split the baby 20 years ago when we were
still a little fresher
the the nerves were still a little more
raw after going broke yeah we probably
would have parked it yeah in a high
yield savings and we're not taking any
risks because sharon was so terrorized
yes emotionally by what we went through
that it took a decade for her to go and
we had to have a big old pile of money
to where she could go oh if you screw
that up over there it ain't gonna kill
you and she's still one of the most
frugal people i know oh my god the woman
will pick up an old used golf ball right
like no one i have ever seen we have a
collection of old used golf she's over
the weeds
she's gonna get bit by a snake
getting getting a golf ball that's worth
50 cents because it's already been hit
by the mower yeah it's unbelievable the
woman is uh yeah yeah she no frugal
frugal don't even touch it yeah all
right and and that's a compliment mark
that's a total count to compliment my
darling eric's in new york city hey eric
what's up
how you doing dave better than i deserve
man how can i help
yes um i
have credit card debt about 25 000
and two of them total 20 000 my credit
union is offering
a 1.99
uh to and i was thinking about
refinancing it
uh those two larger debts because it's
about four hundred dollars in interest
that i'm paying every single month while
i'm doing the baby steps i'm on baby
step one
so you owe you
you owe 40 000 on plastic
no i owe 25 000 on plastic oh
right two of them total 20. i got you
okay and you're gonna you're going to
refinance 20 of the 25
right okay and uh
what do you make a
year 100 okay over 100 you know it's odd
this is the same conversation we were
just having a minute ago but he was on
the investing side and you're on the
debt side
you can do this if you want to do it
here's the danger
you're gonna think you actually did
something
you think this is a big deal
you don't have a four hundred dollar
problem my man
you have a twenty five thousand dollar
problem
when you address the 25 000 problem with
the idiocy spending you've been doing
like you've been in congress on plastic
when you address that deep down in your
soul you're going to get out of debt
really really fast on 25 000 making 100.
you're not going to be in debt very long
interest is not your problem
but if you want to lower the interest
it'll help you a tiny bit here's the
deal five percent of you getting out of
debt is refinancing this 95 of you
getting out of debt is you looking in
the mirror and getting pissed off
and chunking on this thing and beating
the snot out of it because
mathematically 95 of this is not going
to be an interest problem mathematically
this is going to be youth chunking money
on this because you're mad you're sick
and tired of being sick and tired i'm
not living like this anymore
you are 95 of the secret sauce that that
level of
you hearing me dude
yes so how long would it take if i just
left it
two months longer
you saved two months
i might have missed that by a few days
one way or another but my point is four
hundred dollars is forty eight hundred
dollars a year
and you're going to be out of debt in a
year and so
uh you know we cut it in half because
halfway through the year you're going to
have the debt half paid down so it's not
4 800 a year you're going to save it's
going to be more like 2 400 a year in
this year that you get out of debt in
one year
and so you're saving 2 400 bucks 200
bucks a month at the end of the day and
how fast does how much does that apply
to a 2500 oh i was right it's 10 there
we go look at that so yeah you know
so it's probably it's between a month
and two months you're going to say it's
okay to do it i'm not mad about you
doing it but what i don't want you to do
eric the thing people do with that
consolidation is they feel like they did
something and they think they fixed it
with this loan and you cannot borrow
your way out of debt
yeah i mean
that's what they're selling is saving
money and then you kind of lean on that
instead of the intensity that you're
talking about and you you have this
frustration like i gotta get out of debt
and then you think you did something and
then you look up a year later and you're
still in exactly the same place i got a
lot of lower payments you gave me a line
what's that he doesn't have an interest
problem he has an intensity problem
that's what you're teaching it's a good
line well you gave it to me i like it i
didn't say it you said it i'll let you
have it take your notes over here folks
you can own it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
help you learn how to live well i'm
george campbell ramsey personality
joined today by my good friend dr john
deloney and we are here to help you take
the right next step in your journey
whether that's money relationships
mental health boundaries
in-laws anxiety we are here for you
today america so give us a call the
number to call triple eight eight two
five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five john we are hot off
the building wealth live event we just
did in las vegas last night yeah we
landed uh like about an hour ago and
then got in your high performance
battery battery-powered car thank you
for not making fun of it like dave does
no it's pretty fast it's pretty fast uh
elon got us here quick and
yeah we made it man we barely made it
it's good light speed i love it well
we're here for you triple eight eight
two five five two two five serena's
kicking off this hour in champaign
illinois serena welcome to the show
hi thank you for having me absolutely
how can john and i help
well so i just graduated college in
december cool and i graduated with zero
debt and i started this new job i have
about
23 000 in my account right now and i
don't know what to do with it i'm on my
own i have rent and stuff but well let
me high five you first because you're
amazing yeah we don't get a lot of calls
when people call and say what do i do
with all this extra money
very well done serena so what's your
what's your career now
i am a structural design engineer
for chas being an associate
structural design engineer
okay you're really smart so that
explains it john you designed bridges
yeah hey listen
just take a look around the country we
need you thank you for doing what you do
bridges are important that's awesome
okay so you got 23k sitting in savings
what's your whole financial picture so
you're completely debt free right now do
you have any other money in savings
um
i have a 401k and a roth
but other than that no
okay so this 23 000 is your total liquid
cash
basically yeah okay well it sounds like
a large portion of this is going to be
your emergency fund
do you have that already or is that is
this it
that's it okay so what i would do is i
would block off a portion of that three
to six months of expenses and put that
in a savings account maybe a high yield
savings account a money market account
and just park it for emergencies
uh what would that look like for you do
you know that number off the top of your
head
um it's probably around
7
000
okay let's round up to 10 for easy
numbers so now you've got 13 left over
are you renting right now
yes
do you have uh any desire to get in a
home in that area
i'm not quite sure yet since i just
started i mean i really like my job but
i don't know where it's going to take me
quite yet so you don't know if you're
really planting your roots here
right okay well you're already are you
investing 15 of your income into that
401k or ira
10
10
so at this point if you're completely
debt free and now you have that
emergency fund i'm going to bump that
investing up to 15
how old are you
23. 23. serena you're gonna be a
multi-millionaire and you're so smart
you got your whole life ahead of you so
i feel good about this i wouldn't rush
anything but the next step in your
journey would probably be a down payment
on a house and so i would continue to
save up set the money aside for the
emergency fund the rest becomes a down
payment fund maybe you need to upgrade a
car eventually things of that nature but
i want you to enjoy some of this people
like you they tend to be
such sticklers with the budget and
saving john that it's hard for them to
let go of any of it and enjoy it yes hey
serena in 30 seconds can you do me a
huge favor solve a lifelong mystery for
me
yeah
what are those wires hanging down from
some of these giant bridges what do they
do
the liars
um
yeah
i guess it keeps the bridge from falling
down since you call them tension wires
well that kind of makes me feel
different
yeah it keeps it
so that the bridge isn't neither in
uh compression or tension so that it's
stable
i'm so glad serena's in this field and
not you john i just gotta say america is
happy that i'm not designing bridges wow
i didn't know they were called tension
wires now i know there you go i know so
much more now well
let's go back to serena and her problems
john it's not all about you and your
desire to know about you and i i do what
i can to avoid using google and so i met
a person and she could help me out with
that question well serena i would sit
down and maybe it's with a friend of
yours uh someone that you trust someone
that you admire and help
set some goals for your life of hey what
are my next things what's my one year
goal what's a five-year goal what's a
10-year goal and start to go i want to
go on two awesome vacations i'm gonna
start planning for that saving for that
i want to upgrade the car in two years
here's what that looks like here's what
i want here's the kind of house that i'm
looking at here's the price point here's
the down payment start to get a little
bit nerdy and excited about that future
and that will definitely help guide
where that money's going
any thoughts on that john no i think
that's i think that's super wise it's so
rare to hear somebody that is that that
ahead of the game right that is done
followed the steps all the way through
college gotten out debt-free and it's
now sitting on a pile of cash so what do
i do with that now and we talked about
this at the event last night but with
the crippling student loan debt yeah 1.7
trillion
people want to be in serena shoes where
they graduate and they go oh i have
options yeah i have money left over yeah
but most of america
can't because they graduate and they
thought they were going to make 100
grand but they make 50. and they didn't
understand that a hundred thousand
dollars of student loans with interest
looks like a 1200 monthly payment right
and i think it's real important to note
that when you find these transition
points in your life whether it's
graduating from high school graduating
from college getting married you know
all you're always going to have a series
of questions
and i always want to land on the side of
which which set of questions are going
to be questions about freedom and
opportunity
and not questions of survival and so
she's not asking questions like hey i
just got a my dream gig i am a an
engineer and i'm really smart and i
gotta create new job i don't know how
i'm gonna get to move there because i
don't have i don't know how i'm gonna
i'm gonna make rent in this town right
she's asking questions of opportunity
what can i do with this extra money that
i have how do i steward this manager
this way and folks like serena um they
make decisions along the way in college
about
i'm not gonna put this night of drinks
on the credit card i'm not like they
make different choices i'm gonna take a
semester off and work so that i can keep
doing this debt free and it's not pretty
and it's not it's not it's not in the
quote unquote the plan
it's not how they draw it up in the
magazines or the movies but i'm just
going to keep figuring out ways to do
this and suddenly you look up and you're
23. yeah it's no surprise that she's
done really well academically she's
figured out a way to do it financially
and then now she's in the spot that
she's in well let me remind our
listeners john our millionaire study
that we did over 10 000 of them the
number one profession engineer yeah and
engineers understand systems and if you
follow a process it leads you to a
certain result right and so people like
serena and engineers out there they're
the most likely to become millionaires
because they're willing to follow a
proven plan that's right they're willing
to use the tension wire i'm just kidding
i was trying i was you're i was hoping
to make a bridge now i was gonna try we
were so close i'm not that smart well
hey we're here for you this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
call us and we will guide you wherever
you find yourself in this wildlife this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
doloni listen folks one of the most
important types of insurance you can
have is car insurance or motorcycle
insurance if you live on the edge like
john
and fun fact it's actually the law
and most americans don't have enough car
insurance and you're probably one of
them so if you get into an accident you
don't have enough insurance you'll have
to pay for your own car repairs and
medical bills plus the other driver's
car repairs and their medic medical
bills and their passengers medical bills
this is a big yikes this can cost you
thousands of dollars or even worse it
can get you sued
so you've got to have the right car
insurance in place and that's why we
created a network of endorsed local
providers or elps these are licensed
independent insurance agents you can
trust to do things the ramsey way
john and i both have elps in our lives
and i love calling them up to make sure
that i'm covered i have enough coverage
and that i'm doing everything i need to
keep myself covered
they're going to shop around to get the
best value on the coverage you actually
need you may have too much and they'll
teach you how to understand your car
insurance so you can feel confident
you're covered they're going to put your
needs first they're not here to make a
buck they want to help you period so if
you're ready to work with an insurance
agent who's actually in your corner
visit
ramseysolutions.com
auto to connect with a ramsey trusted
elp that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash auto
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five desiree joins
us in phoenix desiree welcome to the
ramsay show
hello i can't believe i'm actually
talking to you guys i can't believe it
either i'm stunned i'm stunned we're so
happy to talk to desiree in phoenix
what's going on with you
well i am needing some advice i'm
finding myself in a crossroad in my life
and i'm not really
sure which way to turn
so long story short i
13 years ago i'm 33 right now
and i went to school for nursing and i
had finished all my prereqs for it way
back in the day like a million years ago
and
i never finished and then just job after
job
i find myself i have a really good job
right now i love what i do it is not in
the medical field
um
but
uh
last year
i'm probably gonna cry
um
i lost i lost my brother no i'm so sorry
copied
yeah no man so um
being
being with him in the hospital
it
opened my eyes and something inside me
just switched and
being there i realized that
being a nurse is what i'm supposed to do
so
i am going through the process right now
of
going back to school um i'm going to be
starting a class here in the summer
to work my way to that and
i was just offered a promotion
at my current job now and i'm just
really torn
if i should take it
or if i should
kind of stay where i'm at
and focus on my school
first off i am so sorry about your
brother um
so much loss last few years i'm so so
sorry you love that dude what was his
name what was his name
paul hilarious he's a funny guy and
yes he was
one of the best humans that ever walked
this planet
so good
it was tough are you um are you married
i am not i am divorced and i am a single
mom to an 11 year old
man i hate to be the person that comes
next after having that kind of example
in your life right your brother set the
bar higher right
yeah that's awesome
all right so
one of the cornerstones of healing from
grief
you'll miss your brother forever okay
and anyone who says you just need to get
over reading that kind of language is
complete nonsense you're going to miss
your brother forever it will hurt less
you'll be able to breathe
you'll be able to laugh at some of the
memories which is hard to do right now
but you will heal and one of the
cornerstones of that healing is making
meaning of it
who am i going to be in light of how my
life is different because i knew this
person
right how am i going to live
and
it's not uncommon for somebody to spend
some time watching the miracles that
nurses
perform the care the love the attention
and then the hand holding on the back
end and think
they are contributing to the world right
and so you already had that what why did
you why did you not finish your your
your classes back in the day what took
you away from that
well um i was young and dumb and
just got caught up in a job at the time
but i thought oh i'm making great money
i'm
in love with my boyfriend at the time
and just thought
that i didn't really need to do it and
throughout the last 13 years i have
found myself in different life
obstacles you know moving getting a
divorce losing a job and every single
time i'm i always tell myself
i i just need to go back to school i
need to go back to school and finish my
my degree and
what's your current job
um i work for a container shipping
terminal that's based in long beach
um so i deal a lot with imports and
customer service and
uh
uh
you're like george costanza you just do
import exports very cool that's all you
have to say is import exports yeah so
yeah normally i try to find a a link
between what you're doing and this pull
to this not dream job this is a dream
job this is mission for you this is this
has been in your dna for a long long
time
and um
here's i
based on what you've just told me i
don't know how you can't not
do this
and here's the fallacy
um
you're starting nurse salary what's the
comparison between that and what you're
going to be making with this new
promotion is it half is it one-third
um so
nursing based off of what i've looked
online it ranges anywhere from like 70
to
80. okay um
right now i make 74
salary and then
if i get this promotion it would bump me
up to 85. shut the front door in the
face
today
yeah tell them hey i'm grateful for the
opportunity and by felicia i'm going to
to school yes
and i it's real tempting to
think i can't do either or you can okay
you can figure it out it's it's
miserable you can make that work as long
as you can until you get into your
rotations then you may have to
do a semester where you've saved up some
money so that you can live so you can be
at school full time but here's the thing
that's what you
were put on the planet to do and
you got to hold your brother through a
really hard hard season and you're going
to be able to be that blessing for
countless other people in the future
desiree do you have any debt
i am debt free i love to hear that
because this gives you options yeah uh
it gives you a launch pad to do this
without a lot of risk and so here's what
i want you to do i want you to cash flow
all of your nursing education and if
that means you have to take this
promotion and do this for a little while
in order to do that i'm okay with that
what i don't want you to do is go into
debt for this thing and then it becomes
a curse instead of a blessing when you
when you jump and so do it the smart way
there's no crazy urgency here but i know
you have to do this we know that hey and
let me tell you this um you mentioned a
couple of times it's a million years ago
and i'm kind of
my mom went back to school in her 40s
and i was a kid and my little brother my
sister like my mom went back to school
it was tough
like dinners looked different i'll never
forget my mom walked me down when i was
in uh sixth grade and she had the box of
tide and she said on the washer and says
this is how this works
merry christmas this is on right i had
to figure some stuff out right
and let me tell you
watching my mom go back to school
midlife
and be successful
and the the countless
hundreds and hundreds of students that
she has influenced over the years has
been such an inspiration to me
my wife my kids and kids and great
grandkids that my mother will never meet
so you're not too old to do this go get
it do it wise like george says but go
get it this is what you were put on the
planet to do desire hang on the line
kelly's gonna pick up we're gonna send
you a copy of our friend ken coleman's
book from paycheck to purpose to
encourage you along this journey we're
so pumped for you call us back when you
land that nursing job this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
dalone number one national best-selling
author that feels good to say john
congratulations again it's better than
uh
a guy it's just
my buddy yeah actually it feels good
well you already had a doctor in front
of your name so you already had some
cool accolades but this is and it's well
deserved hey here was what was super
cool um after so we get noticed that i'm
number one and i felt pretty good about
it
and then the next day
uh i was and i flew home late real late
and i got home and my daughter woke up
and she was like
did you bring me anything
and i was like no
and she's like uh
and my son came out he's like hey what
are we gonna do this weekend and i was
like maybe talk about how awesome your
dad is oh man and then i ended up
changing my oil and run into the dry
cleaners and uh my life just went on so
it's really cool and then you're about
to helping people and doing do your life
man so john as you know i'm a dog dad
which uh frustrates you to no end just
mainly because that's not a thing not a
thing i just do it to make you angry now
but what i found i have a theory that
kids
caused you to be a little more selfless
and a little more humble
yes is that true correct so i think
everyone should have kids for those
reasons alone and interestingly i think
people
i don't know like you who over-obsess
about their dogs it makes them more
narcissistic and self-centered and a
little bit more self-righteous do you
think i was trying to make you look good
i was like look at this no
yes i think owning dogs makes you but to
be fair i did just show you pictures of
my dogs at daycare
so
on that note we'll take some calls let's
just let this sink in america it's
friday all right let's triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
the number to call triple eight eight
two five five two is it really called
doggie dake here i don't know what they
call it it's an industry term john
america what are we doing
this is the lingo
kale joins us
kale is in atlanta georgia what's up
kale welcome to the show thank you i
appreciate your time how can we help you
so i'm trying to help out my mom uh
she's 71 years old
starting to have some health issues she
has copd so she can't really get around
too well
but she didn't really save right so all
of her money's kind of in her equity
uh for her house which she can't take
care of anymore so i'm trying to figure
out
you know does she go into a different
house that's smaller
but everything is so expensive she would
be in a 30-year loan which i don't like
and i know you guys don't like
and she wouldn't have any money in the
bank because she'd have to put it all
into the new house
or there's just some other option that
i'm not thinking of because renting
sounds you know
the rent's variable every year so i
don't know that that's sustainable
yeah is she
are y'all thinking about long-term care
are you thinking about skilled nursing
where is she there
no she's able to take care of herself
but you know she's not gonna go mow the
yard and she's not gonna you know be
able to vacuum uh you know two-story
house
and do those kinds of things but she can
cook and she can kind of take care of
herself that's not an issue so i i'll
let george answer the finance part but i
feel like you've painted yourself into a
corner here um that i want to free you
from okay uh is this a an important
family house
or is this just her home i mean does
this like have meaning to you
uh it does but i'm not holding on to it
okay
what about mom that's not the issue
uh no i'm sure it was but she said that
she's she's kind of gotten over it so
she's
okay with getting out of it okay i don't
want you to paint yourself into a corner
well with which is we don't have any
money but we can't do this and so now
you hear i'm saying anytime you find
yourself with two options i want you to
shake the snow globe and reevaluate find
more options yeah back out another 20
000 feet another 30 000 feet and go look
at the problem differently because
um a lot of us make
choices that we ultimately regret we get
a real unrealistic sense of urgency and
so if your mom is able to take care of
herself she doesn't need skill nursing
it's just a matter of the house is
increasingly becoming um a lot to
maintain and manage that's a totally
different conversation than
um
we've got to get her out right now we
don't have any money okay
yeah well the the only i think urgency
for me is that since she has no money in
the bank really if something breaks on
the home
she has no money to fix it
okay i think the underlying solution is
she needs to get some control of her
money regardless of her housing
situation she can't keep living with
zero dollars in the bank regardless of
where she lives
so what's her income right now
uh so her income is based on her pension
and uh her social security and it comes
to 2800 a month
okay if she sold the house today what
would she net
uh approximately 200 000
okay so the question is
where can she find a 200 000
one-bedroom 2-bedroom condo town home
in that area
right is that an option have you looked
at the prices
uh yeah i've even engaged a realtor
who's been looking for probably the last
month
with uh no success really everything's
kind of above 300
uh
what's left on our mortgage
uh her mortgage um is 165 left on our
mortgage
how long has she been living in this
house
well let's just say she owes more now
than when she bought the house so
decisions were a lot of decisions there
yeah was there
second mortgages he locks
refinancing all all that stuff all that
stuff
okay
well we need to does she know that she's
on fire like does she have a sense of
urgency that you do
um i think so well i think she just
feels stuck and so
uh she may have just thrown her hands up
at this point i don't really know is
there a chance that um have you are you
married
i am married do you have brothers and
sisters
uh i have a sister uh who yes who lives
out of state okay
um have you all
it doesn't sound like you have i i'd
recommend you all have the conversation
about is there a moment that
one of us if something gets to point a
and then it moves to point b is mom
gonna move in with one of us for a
season
um
i was hoping you were gonna tell me the
house was seven hundred thousand dollars
two hundred grand george even if you
sell it that's not that just gets you a
couple years down the road that's not a
huge
i mean she can take on a smaller
mortgage which would help with her
payment and make it more reasonable with
her income that's the only solution i'm
seeing if this is you sell this house
you clear 35 grand
i mean that you're saying he would net
200 if she sold it you would net 200
yeah she owes 165 she could probably
sell for four oh okay yeah so she would
get 200. so i'm going can she buy
something with cash
so that she doesn't have that expense
she can live off the 2800 but i would
also look at okay how much can she
afford based off of that i'm looking at
i mean
600 700 bucks
yeah approximately and so then i go okay
what mortgage are we willing to take on
for that i don't want to take on any but
i know the housing market's crazy maybe
you wait six more months and see what
happens if things at least uh taper down
with the you know hundred thousand
dollars over asking and 85 people sight
unseen wanting that same place
but i think you're gonna have to help
her paint this new picture of what this
new life looks like and what level of
sacrifice it's going to take
yep can do how old is she
she's 71.
[Music]
so
this is a hard conversation do you live
in the area with her
yeah i live uh probably 30 minutes from
her okay this is um
not a
spring it on you conversation
this is a
um and if your sister is is in
everybody's good graces and would it be
good if she could be a part of this too
uh in person even even if even though
she was out of state and this is
something you plan and say mom we're
going to talk about
finances and we're going to talk about
the future
and so we're going to have a breakfast
together we're going to go somewhere
we're going to y'all i'm going to come
pick you up and bring you back to my
house we're going to meet your house
whatever
and we're going to get very very
specific on the realities here because
the realities here are scary and there's
there's no long-term care insurance
right correct does she have health
insurance through her pension plan
uh no she pays 400 a month for health
insurance
and it's
probably not great right
uh she seems happy with it at least so
well
it takes care of all her her medications
okay and when she does have to go the
doctor she's not having to pay so okay
these are hard conversations with our
our aging parents
and these are done in love and these are
done
i would write down what i'm gonna say
and be very specific about math and then
come up with a few options we can sell
this house and and try to move here you
can rent you can move into my house you
can move in with sister but we gotta
have some really tactical steps for
moving forward yeah this is a mess kale
you can jump onto our mortgage
calculator at ramseysolutions.com and
walk her through the numbers and go hey
listen we're not going to do more than a
15-year i want you to retire with
dignity and enjoy your life and not
stress out every day of how you're going
to make it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined by dr john deloney
john you know what what one of my
favorite things to do in the world is
guess
pet your dog that is on the top it's in
the top look up an app give away dave's
money i love it
especially when he isn't here he can't
defend himself so here's the deal it's a
great time telling everyone we're giving
away 500
every single week in may
plus a grand prize of 3 000
in our ramsey cash giveaway so just
think about this for a second
all the things you can do with that
extra cash
pay off some debt put in the emergency
fund maybe go on a nice trip if you're
debt free
to enter this giveaway go to
slash
ramseysolutions.com
and bonus you can enter every single day
for extra chances to win all month long
no purchase necessary but you must be 18
or older to win sorry kids
and we're not stopping here to help you
crush your financial personal and
professional goals we are putting our
number one best selling books and tools
in the ramsey ten dollar sale that's
sixty seven percent off and i love a
good deal we also have a new addition to
the ramsey ten dollar sale this is very
exciting dr john deloni's questions for
humans conversation cards this is going
to get your family and friends to ditch
the screens for just a moment to
actually connect to real conversations
if you remember what those are
and so john i thought it'd be fun to uh
play a few with you you got some here
yeah which this is out of the uh it's
out of the friends box i thought we were
friends
so we've done the vr the kids we are
parents and kids hey uh if you got this
500 bucks you could upgrade your dog's
package at the doggie daycare thing to
the uh they don't have packages john
okay it's just a neighborhood thing just
don't overthink it you ready for your
first card let's do it all right
questions for humans here we go who in
the room which is me and you john is
most likely to become famous and why oh
clearly me i'm a smoker number one i'm
just kidding
uh probably you because you speak in
complete sentences and you don't mumble
a lot
um that's not the prerequisite you're
being famous you're you're
just deadly handsome and uh
yeah you can grow a beard i can't do
that to be able you have a chiseled
jawline i use my beard to hide
whatever's underneath this that's very
fair i think you'd become famous john
you're more uh you're you've got an
electricity to you yeah it's kind of a
third rail
very dangerous but people are drawn to
that'll get you killed like a moth to a
flame okay there's that number two
what's the best rock song of all time oh
my goodness
it's like choosing your favorite child
that is um the best okay let's run
through real quick the best metal rock
song of all time is walk by pantera the
best
the best just straight up rock song is
probably something off
nickelback's album i'm gonna go with a
hard pass on that one probably off the
black crow's record or maybe the uh guns
rose record so and then probably the
greatest ballad of all time rock ballad
is i remember you by skid row
i get choked up maybe maybe when i see
you smile by bad english
those are good we have very different
tastes i'm going bohemian rhapsody queen
see
it's fantastic it goes places it's epic
it's a journey that's what i want out of
a rock song i just want my heart broken
and all right and repaired in one song
oh gosh what's one word or phrase that
is way overused
i like george i'm just kidding uh i uh
way overused is um
didn't you like write these cards i feel
like you should have answers well i i
mean i didn't have the answers that's
what i wanted to know the answers to
what do you think
i'm going with literally
because 99 of the time
it's not used in the correct sense and
it just bothers me as a grammar nerd
i like that it literally drives me crazy
john um i'll really it drives you crazy
you know i'm a writing like uh i'm
writing is like
i'm a stickler for good writing and when
people write the word that a lot it
makes me crazy passive voice in writing
use an example use it in a sentence um
mr phd
uh we went to the store
versus
the store is where we went to
who talks like that
every freshman through senior college
writer
that's fair what's a fashion trend that
needs to die your skinny jeans have got
to stop
they're too small why are all these cars
a personal attack john well we're
friends we're hanging out
what do you think of fashion trends i'm
going with crocs i think it it was so
lame that it became cool again which is
like how gen z kind of operates yeah
like the less cool it is the more cool
it is i know i've seen like the the
flowery skate shirts are coming back
there like in the night come on guys
those can't come back but no i i think
the if your shoe has a sport mode i'm
out
with the crocs you know you put the back
up that's called sport mode
so they don't slip off
i know
it bothers me i didn't think you could
fall farther you just did that's
impressive
all right last one what's the most
overrated holiday
oh man the most over it
this one's tough man
the most overrated holiday
probably valentine's day
i'm i'm with you on that really yeah
look at us being best friends do you
think i'm gonna choose like easter or
christmas no no way man can't get into
those thorny thorny discussions yeah
valentine's day mostly because every day
you should probably be honoring your
significant other good answer and uh if
you go to a store and think you know
what
i could get a piece of paper and
tell the person i love how i feel in my
own words but
i'm going to pay you 4.95 for you to
some dude in a warehouse to write it and
say it then your relationship i don't
know maybe you should maybe we should uh
well some of us aren't amazing
wordsmiths like you john writing prose
it's a world war ii letter
to the love of your life or you get to
say i love you it's so good you're
sheila
it's been a long hard month
yep see
anyway fantastic all right that's fun
well if you guys want to check that out
way more cars where that came from
there's all kinds of additions you can
get it for just 10 bucks for a limited
time it's a whole bunch of fun and it's
way better than staring at your phones
and pretending like you're connecting
we've also got lots more books and tools
to help you move forward in your life no
matter what area you want to work on so
go check it out ramsay 10 sale at
ramseysolutions.com and enter the ramsey
cash giveaway every single day at
ramseysolutions.com
giveaway good times there john thank you
so much
john joins us in phoenix john welcome to
the show
hi there hi uh john and i'm sorry what's
the uh our other job my name is george
and you're john we got john john and
george perfect
there you there we go the three games
hey listen a quick question i have
i've i currently live in my house that
is fully paid off
holding a job for a sixty thousand
dollars
a year
and i have two rental properties that
are fully paid off wow
i am i am seriously considering selling
these two properties that are rentals
and
uh and just solidify what i've got
invested in there and the equity that
comes along with that
and so by doing that i would like to
know what to do with this cash that i'm
probably going to be cashing in on if
everything works hold on why why are you
selling the rentals that are paid for
um yeah simply i just want to solidify
my investment in there and put it in a
like in a savings account i want to be
able to ride these away because what do
you mean
do you think the housing market cash out
yes
exactly are you are you worried that the
houses will start to lose value soon
uh indeed
where are you getting that from
uh well it's just the way the market is
looking like right now for example it's
so unstable
i mean
the housing market isn't the housing
market keeps going up and up and up
yeah but see here's here's the you're
gonna you're gonna sell the homes that
are appreciating to put your money in
the stock market which is tanking right
now
right
okay now is that a wise idea or not well
that's no
i'm telling you that you're that real
estate is a solid investment and the
fact that they're paid for makes me feel
even better about it are they producing
income
uh yeah some some income indeed one of
them is a version of thousand and the
other one two thousand so you're
bringing in three thousand a month
exactly what's the what is are these two
pieces of property worth together
uh together probably about seven hundred
and fifty thousand dollars whoa
i feel like you're under charging
they should be producing more income for
paid off rentals
indeed you're right about that
so i would focus on that before you sell
i'm not mad if you sell them and you
want to put your money into the market
but i want you to have a good reason
that's not grounded in fear what what's
the question underneath the question
uh there's something
do you want the money
if i don't get the money i just see
here's the thing i got in mind if i do
do you remember the
early two thousand when uh when our
market crashed and the real i didn't
went down yes
i'll be able to cash in on that
and i want to be able to put that money
away and be ready to reinvest whenever i
don't man i don't think this plan is
fully baked i would sit tight on these
homes don't let fear greed and headlines
no money not when you've got paid off
houses yep i'd put pause on that man
turn off the tv for a little while
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get connected in your relationships we
want to help you learn how to live well
give you the right next step wherever
you might find yourself in this journey
i'm george campbell joined today by dr
john delony open phones this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's eight eight eight eight two five
five two two five timothy kicks off this
hour in dc timothy welcome to the show
hey guys thank you so much i'm excited
to have an opportunity to ask my
question
um so i have a three-part question uh
first i would say i have i just was
given the ability to move anywhere in
the united states i currently own a
currently owe 689 on my house
it is worth 940 000.
that's the first note the second note is
i have a rental property that i hold 85
000 on and i net
you know the
the rent i received was like 1200.
i have a car that i owe 68 000
if i was to sell it i would walk away
with 23 000.
so my my question is i have the ability
to
become debt free if i sell this house
and do
and take the profit
pay off the other house
and then sell my car and take the 23
000. so my question is if i do that
where does that put me when i go to move
somewhere else
um
that's awesome timothy well you got a
lot going on here why do you want to
become debt free i'm curious
oh you know i just start listening to
your station probably uh
a month or two ago just in the morning
we're taking my kids to school
and i'm starting to catch the vibe of
you know uh the freedom that freedom uh
that free the freedom that i can have
but from a financial and this way from a
financial perspective now
uh we rank in about 275 combined awesome
we don't have any credit cards
so i'm just i'm at a sweet spot
i would call a sweet spot from uh like
you know managing my bills and having
residual income
but i just don't know if i move
and what's the worry with
moving
moving is if i pay off everything as i
mentioned and
i get down to the location i want to
move to the housing market is the way it
is
so
out of the number the calculation that i
uh ran with all those numbers i could
probably have maybe like 80 or 90 000
you know
left over if i paid off everything the
rental property sold his house sold my
car
um so you want to keep the rental
property but pay it off is that right
i need guidance okay
yeah well uh
george is going to help you walk through
the math of this um i'm going to tell
you like just
at the 30 000 foot view
um you do really well
and it's you've got a you've you've got
an incredible income clearly you're good
at what you do because the your employer
just said i don't even care where you
live um we want you on our team that bad
and so you are clearly way out in front
of the game
the part that's dragging you down is
that you are
trying to to look the part too
and it's keeping you from becoming super
wealthy generational
tran transformationally wealthy okay
and so it's it's gonna take a season of
you not looking like you make 275 000 a
year
and then you're gonna hang out with
people and you're gonna realize they
make four hundred thousand dollars a
year and you'd never know it
i walked i ran into dave when we were
doing something here in las vegas dave
ramsey himself who's worth hundreds of
millions of dollars and he was wearing
shorts and a t-shirt that i could get in
academy and that's not me blasting him
that's just saying there's a certain
level that when you cross a line you're
not impressing nobody you know what i
mean
and so right now you've got a million
dollar house here a rental house over
here a really nice car over here
and your money's sprayed out everywhere
and you've got this
concentrated nuclear reactor of a salary
man and so here's what i'd say before i
hand over to
george if i'm in your seat like if you
and i just trade places today what i
would do is i would sell my house
i would think real hard about selling
that rental house real hard about
selling that rental house i would sell
my car i would move to the town and i
would rent in this new city for probably
six months to a year and i would pile up
cash and find the place in the house
that i want to live
and that's gonna you're gonna go what
you're crazy you know how much money i
make and i'd say exactly right so george
take it on the map yeah i love what
john's putting down over here uh timothy
here's the deal that rental property you
said it brings in 1200 a month
yes that's 14k a year you make 275. this
rental property is not changing your
life
correct it might feel good because
you're like oh i'm a slick real estate
investor but did you make that in a
month in a month hey how much is the
house worth if you sold it
um they've been trying to give me like
189 190. and you owe 85.
yes okay so here's my my uh napkin math
you'd net 250 on your personal residence
you'd net 23 on the car sale and you net
100 from the rental sale does that sound
right
yes sir so you're looking at 375 in cash
if you make all these moves
and then you'd have to go spend 25 grand
and buy yourself an f-150 or a camry and
you'd have to just look in the mirror
and go yep i'm that guy for this season
um or get yourself something nice you
have 375 000 in cash right um and the
world is your oyster timothy you said
you can move anywhere do you know where
you'd want to go
i yes i do but i want to say this in
case somebody's
oh you got it you got it you got it
yeah so here's my thinking though if i
had 375 thousand dollars in cash and i
made 275 what would it look like to pay
cash for a property somewhere be
completely debt free get a cheaper car
and then you go i make 275 and i don't
have any payments in the world you know
how quickly you can build wealth you
know how quickly you could buy rental
properties you know how much earlier you
could retire if you made these moves
does that excite you
it it it does um so the one caviar not
and that's why i'm calling for advice no
pride is i feel like we work so hard and
it's just
truck and that's just because i wrecked
my wife's 2010 prius right
um i've had to take my pride and set it
aside
and say i i value
my kids and my grandkids having a
different kind of life more than
having a fancy leather seat in my car
on a depreciating asset
i've had to say i am willing to and by
the way it's not a sacrifice at all to
have a hundred i mean to have a thousand
or fifteen hundred square foot less on
my house size
so that
when i die
my grandkids are gonna inherit infinite
amounts of money
see what i'm saying like so the the why
we're doing this is way way bigger than
how hard i work and i just had to change
the picture because the our culture
tells us you work so hard so you deserve
this and my thought is i work so hard so
my family's going to live differently
forever
amen timothy if you can stop caring what
other people think it is a superpower my
man dude you can do this you can build
wealth because the truth is there's
people making 40 000 that have a higher
net worth than you that should make you
mad i want you to build your net worth
and not build your reputation you don't
need this you're doing so so good make
these moves you're not gonna regret it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right imagine the energy of a
jam-packed arena filled with people
ready to experience what it means to
live life to the fullest now picture all
of your favorite speakers together in
one stage empowering you with tools and
principles that will create unstoppable
momentum in your life
that is smart conference that's right
folks smart conference is back it's been
three years since we've done this event
and we are so pumped to get it back on
the road
in the great city of dallas texas
dallas we're headed your way on saturday
october 22nd mark your calendars it's
going to be an amazing time this is our
biggest event of the entire year you
don't want to miss it it's a day-long
opportunity to get advice from leading
experts on money personal growth
leadership mental health relationships
and your career and you're going to
leave with all the knowledge and
motivation you need to reach your goals
and live the life that you want and all
of us here at ramsay will be there
including my friend right next to me dr
john dolone and special guests craig and
amy grochelle from life church they're
coming too they're going to be talking
about marriage it's going to be fire as
the kids say john
tickets
tickets are 39 that's amazing this is a
full day event for 39 yeah it's pretty
cool you barely can go to chipotle with
your family for 39
this is wild get your tickets right now
before they sell out go to
ramsaysolutions.com
slash events if you want to learn more
and this is a destination event so if
you don't live in dallas texas you
should go to dallas texas for this event
people travel from all over the country
it's going to be a packed arena
and john's going to be there rachel dave
ken you name it yeah it'll be a blast
and uh if it's anything like last night
in vegas with our building wealth live
event which five of us were on stage
that was a party it's going to be
electric so go get your tickets ramsay
solutions.com
events it's going to be a bunch of fire
emojis right in a row that's not a thing
do people still do that i don't know
it's true where's gen z when you need
them to keep us cool
all right derek joins us up next he's in
west palm beach derek welcome to the
show
sorry i'm having a hard time hearing you
man speak directly into your phone
not any better derek okay we may have to
hang on and see if we can get you later
all right we're gonna move on right now
to madeline in naples florida madeline
welcome to the show
hi gentlemen thanks for taking my call
absolutely did i get it right is it
madeline
you could say madeline
i knew it was madeline that was very
nice of you to say it that way it's such
a madeleine thing to do all right how
can we you could just call me whatever
yeah um so we just found out we're
expecting our fourth baby in december
party
thanks yeah it is we're so excited um
but i do have a question about moving
from this area um versus increasing our
shovel
okay so we're on baby step three we live
in a really expensive area obviously in
naples um the amount of time saving up
for our house just feels really far away
for us our rent is taking up about 33
percent of our take-home which is about
62 000 a year
um
and we my husband and i both work some
side gigs i do some data entry on the
side
and i'm also a stay-at-home mom he's a
chemist
um and uh we have family in the midwest
we're interested in moving closer to
either kentucky or wisconsin
but uh the opportunities he has at work
are pretty good so we're just having
trouble weighing the options so he'd
have to uproot his career if you guys
made the move to kentucky or wisconsin
no
because we're looking there's lots of
job opportunities for chemists in
kentucky or wisconsin we would we would
chase the job but those are the two
states we've been kind of eyeing
okay so why do you want to stay where
you are
um
the picture you just painted says it
makes sense just to go be with family
and go make good money and go chase it
um yeah why would you want to stay where
you are
um well there's a little bit of fomo i
think with fear missing out it's pretty
glamorous area we live in and you know
there's the beach and this is vacation
land why would we leave we also have
family here as well his parents are here
and they have a house and they're rooted
here i think so
uh it's it's hard to part from them
they've been a big part of our lives and
the grandkids so let's flip it around
what if you just never moved just stay
put
i think we would do pretty well
is there fomo there was not moving
um i have a little bit of that because
i've been away from my family in the
midwest for like
going on nine years ish so i have that
yearning
um but we both are okay with staying
like i am okay with shane florida
um
it doesn't feel like we're gonna get a
whole lot of margin as soon as i'd like
it it feels like saving for a house is
just going to take such a long time hold
on but you guys have a massive income
what's your yearly income
62 uh take home your your take-home pay
is 62.
yeah oh okay i thought you said you were
paying that in rent i was like this is
absurd okay all right that changes
things
yeah two important things okay
yeah number one
you're allowed to miss your family and
really want to strongly consider moving
back to be around them
and somehow you've become
over probably the course of your
lifetime you've become the peacekeeper
and you want to make sure everybody else
is okay before we talk about what i'm
need
yeah and your needs have value
and in fact
the greatest way to
honor your
spouse the greatest way to honor your
kids is to speak your needs out loud and
have that conversation probably multiple
conversations
squashing that stuff
will find it it will make its way out
and it's going to make its way out in
all sorts of ways that you don't intend
okay
the second thing is
um
you are allowed to say that you have a
desire
with kid number four coming that i want
to have our own home
tired of renting definitely and yes
things are shiny here and yes they're
nice and the water's great and all that
we can't afford to live here
full stop
and so we can visit here your parents
have a house that's one
those are conversations that you need to
have and you have them in loving and
direct and respectful and kind and
dignified ways
but somehow you've convinced yourself
that your needs go way beyond everybody
else's even to the point that you make
up stories about other people's needs
and insert them above your needs and
they may not even be real right
yeah yeah
so here's your homework assignment i
want you to sit down and say right i put
a piece of paper and write down not with
a with a with a with a computer with a
pen like old school like it's 1986. and
i want you to write
i need
and i want at the top of a paper and you
may have never even thought about this
or you've got it
and i want you to write that stuff down
all the way to
my wife needs this thing called chit
chat
not super sure
what it's all about but i just know that
um
at the end of the day she likes me just
to sit while she's like
doing stuff and we just we just talk
i don't fully get it but here's what she
told me hey this is important for me and
it's important for me to help meet her
needs there and it's as simple as
sitting down for about an hour every day
no kids and just having grown up
communication and it's fantastic okay
yeah that's just a small need every all
the way up to
our intimacy life are we have another
kid coming we've got this i don't see
you um are you breaking bad he's a
chemist right who knows what
conversations y'all need to have
you just need to have them right all the
way up to yeah i want to make a plan to
own our own home and i want to move back
to the midwest
and yeah
letting those things be heard can you do
that
for sure yeah he's a great listener
awesome awesome and
most of the time when people will speak
their needs out loud
and look at somebody across the table
from them and say i love you and i love
us and here's what i want for us the
conversation's totally different when it
when you wait and wait and wait in 14
years from now your last kid's going off
to college and you just have an
implosion then your husband's looking
there in the ash of what just happened
and goes what happened like what did i
do sure yeah then madeline realized that
neither of these decisions are fatal so
don't make it this life like what if we
do the wrong thing
you can move you cannot move and your
life's gonna be okay but what i'm
feeling is that if you stay in naples
and you got four kids and you can't
afford to have any margin to save up for
a house which is something that you told
me you wanted then you're not really
living in a dream area you're living a
nightmare because you're frustrated
every day by your situation yeah you're
living next to rich people doing their
rich thing lives
going up forever so uh wishing you the
best is you have these hard
conversations pulling for you and uh
good luck with whatever decision you
decide to go with appreciate the call
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up america thank you for joining
us this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined today by dr john delony
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window covering you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsey to get the best
all right today's question comes from
trevor in idaho trevor writes i'm
looking for advice on transitioning from
baby step two to baby step three
we will be debt free soon and my wife
wants to celebrate with a small trip
costing around 2 500 bucks
i want to continue asap on our emergency
fund what would you advise
um
well i'm sensing some marital tension
here because he wants one thing she
wants another that's right um and
congrats on being debt-free by the way
it's awesome
this is an interesting one john because
after baby step two
you're like we did it we can live our
life now we don't have payments anymore
and yet you're still not out of the
woods
is you got to zero right you got to you
got baseline yeah to flat earth right uh
i just stepped in it with that that's
not flat jumping youtubes you've been
hanging out with the rachel cruz that's
right it's not flat it's not you know
what i mean but yeah you get to zero and
you work so hard to dig out of a hole to
just be like all right and now we're on
just basic ground now and now we have to
do the work to start building right yeah
well if you look at it this way
you're gonna spend 2500 on a vacation
when you only have a thousand dollars
in your bank account with your your
starter emergency fund still so that
scares me to death and so i'm gonna use
that and go okay
what if instead of we we put this
vacation on hold the big one but we
still do a real small trip maybe it's
local maybe it's an airbnb maybe it's
just a weekend getaway how can we do
this for four hundred dollars instead of
twenty five hundred dollars that's right
last uh last summer my family man we we
have some financial goals that we're
trying to hit and we're
i'm being kind of we're all being kind
of obnoxious about them um we had a
really rad
vacation at the koa and we rented a
cabin and we all piled in it and it was
not glamorous and it was outside and the
kids ran around everybody had a blast
and so um there and it was like 400
bucks right it wasn't that super
expensive of a three or four day getaway
or go have a fun night so i think i
think the answer here is both both hand
you need to do something to mark this
occasion do something fun go have a
obnoxious dinner go spend the night in
the airbnb somewhere if you need
something shiny and fancy or go spend a
couple of days at a koa somewhere go do
something like that but don't blow two
and a half times your emergency fund
telling yourself how great you are
because you just made baseline man
because you deserve a vacation i'd much
rather see you fully fund that emergency
fund and then take five thousand bucks
and go do something fantastic yeah so
it's not a no it's just a not now yeah
and when you look at it that way you go
okay we can still start planning we can
get excited about it do something man
yeah do something and it's around the
corner we found that baby step three
saving up that fully funded emergency
fund takes most people about six months
right so we're not talking hey three
years from now we're gonna go on
vacation we're talking six months from
now or maybe eight months if we need
another few months to save up for that
vacation uh but once you do that man
it's gonna be a peaceful place you're
not gonna be on that vacation going oh
my gosh what if some what if we get flat
tires what if the hvac goes out we're
still broke that's right so good
question or we're right back in debt
where we were right yeah thanks for the
question trevor appreciate it open
phones this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five derrick joins us
he's back from west palm beach derek can
we hear you now
i don't know you telling me there we go
thank you for taking my call what's
going on
uh i had a basic call i hate to wish you
guys with um you know such a basic
question
no such thing there's no such thing
brother you ain't wasting anybody's time
i'm glad you called man all right thank
you thank you
um i traveled back and forth to work
about an hour so
my question was um kind of same similar
to the the email you guys just got
but mine was for uh is it okay to dip
into my emergency fund a little bit to
purchase a better car not a new car uh
just better on fuel i drive a 05 grand
cherokee
it's a cylinder it's horrible on gas and
i pay about 500 bucks a month on gas
so
it's yeah it's just killing me
so um
and i don't want to finance the cars
that's
regardless of what you guys say that's
just not something i want period
well we weren't going to do it
yeah we'd never say that yeah
not on this show
okay that's a great question so here's
the deal here's how i look at this
situation
your emergency fund
has very specific parameters and so ask
yourself these three questions is it
urgent
is it necessary and is it unexpected
and the truth is if you answer all these
three honestly
you're gonna say no no and no
so here's what i'm going to do i do
think you need a better car with better
gas mileage but we're going to do is
save up on top of the emergency fund in
a separate savings account to buy this
new car or use cars what do you want to
get man
uh anything that's what's in this land
i'm not picky
so what's the car worth if you sold it
today in this market what could you get
for it
uh
geez i haven't priced it and uh recently
but it was worth probably a little above
a thousand i mean i've put probably a
thousand bucks five times yeah i put
maybe like five times as much into it
hold on you're saying your your grand
cherokee 05 is worth a thousand dollars
in this market
i don't know about today uh but when i
pressed it a little while ago that's
what it was okay this is your homework
go actually check on kbb.com go see what
similar cars are selling for on auto
trader carvana just go and and do some
research to figure out what you can get
for this car because that helps you
figure out what the gap is to get to the
next car how much cash do you have
right i have about 15. and that's your
fully funded emergency fund or is that
more
right i know that's the emergency fund
okay is that three months or six months
six months
okay are you single
uh single but i do have a girlfriend
okay what do you do for work
i'm a truck driver
okay for uh costco
cool
well if you want to uh
john's getting at is limiting your
emergency fund shrinking that down to
maybe three or four is that okay yeah i
mean if he's got a stable job there's no
chance you know if you're a single guy
and you're like hey i can go hustle and
go get something else i mean it's still
you know when you have two stable
incomes i feel a lot better about
leaning towards three months yeah so
this is it's a little bit of risk but
he's not tanking he's not taking all 15
000 and going well i have no money in
the bank but i have a car right i yeah
so did you hear what we're saying derek
if you've got a fully six-month funded
six-month emergency fund it doesn't give
me heartburn to roll back to say okay
i've got four months of emergency fund
and i'm gonna take that gap
plus trade my car in and um in fact i'm
going to save one more month and get
another thousand bucks here i'm going to
scratch and claw and say if i'm going to
take that money and go find me
a four-cylinder car like that that
didn't what's your income hurt my
feelings
i make about 97.98 oh come on eric why
don't you leave with that derrick you
make 97 000 a year you're debt-free with
an emergency fund
uh i except for my home
okay what's stopping you from saving up
six to eight thousand dollars in a few
months
um other than well i invest a lot into
my uh i have my 401k and my raw stuff
what percentage are you investing from
your income um 20. okay let's taper that
down because it's your life's not all
about investing right now when you need
this car so i'm gonna yeah yeah that's a
car man
once you do that you're gonna give
yourself a little raise a little margin
to save up for this car
and beyond the 15 i want you attacking
the house
okay i didn't i didn't cast that uh you
guys were both talking at the same time
so i want you to invest 15 of your
income instead of 20. and that 5 that
you get back into your life now is going
to give you some margin to save up for
this car very quickly so i'm doing some
research of home you i'm going to yoda
honda sorry toyota they get very upset
with me for saying toyota uh so here's
what you're going to do look up what
these cars are going to cost for maybe a
2010
civic a 2010 camry something like that
and then figure out the gap figure out
how long it's going to take and go get
that car and sell the grand cherokee but
we're not dip i wouldn't dip into the
emergency fund more than two or three
grand okay
you got this man good luck safe travels
out there this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
first john 5 14.
this is the confidence we have in
approaching god that if we ask anything
according to his will he hears us
corey ten boom said what wings are to a
bird and sails to a ship so is prayer to
the soul
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined by dr john delony
now if you don't know dr john baloney
has his own show aptly named the dr john
deloney show and john you get a lot of
calls about narcissism and that can be a
squishy word people have a lot of
opinions on what that means
can you help us understand this yeah and
we got this article here um but
narcissism and how they
they have toxic money habits that often
go ignore or unnoticed but i think it's
important to step back and say okay
what's a narcissist that's a word that
is
way overused in our culture it's just
someone i don't like it's it's a nice we
have a lot of jerks and a lot of
exhausted people
a pathological narcissist worthy of the
diagnosis of narcissism personality
disorder and pd like that that's a those
are
very different levels so a clinically
speaking
uh
narcissistic personality means someone
has a very inflated sense of
self-importance a need for admiration a
lack of empathy as my friend dr cloud
henry cloud says narcissistic people
need to feel special
they have an inflated self-worth they're
always looking to feel better and they
will use you
for those means to prop them up you're a
pawn in their scheme think of a dementor
i'm going to get my spirit and my
self-worth by taking from you that
happened in space jam i remember that
they sucked the powers from the
basketball
just trying to connect and relate here
john it's all right who to like kids
eating cereal face jam fans they
understand oh my gosh leave it to george
to bring this back to a lucky charms
commercial so here's the deal so you've
got folks who um are jerks we've got
folks who are rude we've got folks who
are struggling with things and they they
can lash out at people they can hurt
other people
narcissists spend their life
always trying to fill ex internal holes
with external solutions
i'm gonna i need everything from you i
need everything from this they're gonna
they're gonna they're gonna try to look
a certain way even though they're not
paying their bills right so we circle
back and i assume it's never enough
because they're not actually it's an
endless yes and it's actually a facade
to cover up for somebody who's really
hurting um and it's a way to create
space and to look the part here but it's
just this pervasive sense of this
fantasy or this behavior that i'm better
than everybody and everybody around me
there's a lack of empathy and it goes on
and on it's this we've been around
people who have these
fantasies about success
what are you talking about like i like
yeah my job i'm this
i don't i don't think that's the case at
all right
what a narcissist often does is it makes
you they make you feel crazy in their
presence
because they talk so emphatically about
how great they are and how wonderful
they're doing and how great their money
is and how incredible their sex life is
and you begin to think like i i'm not
seeing that at all i thought you were an
assistant manager
and i know you assistant to the regional
to the region and i know you make 41 000
like i don't and so you begin to feel
crazy right and that's why gaslighting's
so important such a particular part of
narcissists but so we we land here with
these five toxic money habits that often
go unnoticed or ignored
um in this article here from from cnbc
so it says number one
narcissists are often secretive about
their finances they keep you in the dark
they say things like let me be in charge
of the finances so you have to stress
about it and this can happen in business
too right um a narcissistic co-founder
might casually tell you the article says
since you're the creative genius i'll
just manage the boring money stuff which
is a
an incredibly subversive power move yeah
to take over there's a lot of
deceitfulness a lot of deception it's
about getting power right number two
there are only
generous with money in public spending
large amounts of money on others
can be a way to get people to like them
but then they're really stingy and
private right
they might cover dinner for colleagues
or give gifts just for the show and then
their wife is like hey
the kids need some clothes and they're
like oh you don't figure that out on
your own right that's narcissism so a
lot of showing is happening here that's
right they're willing to do it but as
long as other people see it because the
purpose of covering that meal is not to
honor and love and serve the people who
are at the meal it's to demonstrate to
the room how great and wow john's such
an amazing guy so generous that's right
yeah number three they skimp on the
essentials here so they can be grandiose
when it comes to self-serving
unnecessary spending like buying
designer watches they can't afford
we see this a lot with um i've got six
figures of student loans but i've got
this mercedes and four rental properties
that i've bought on because i want to
have this appearance to show the world
how great i am those intimate
relationships with them may have to
quietly save money on the side i hear
that a lot
i have to create a separate world so
that i can live right whether that's
people avoiding abuse that's people
avoiding um starvation right i got
i'm pilfering money over here into a
secret account so the kids can have
clothes for school that kind of stuff
and it just doesn't even enter the mind
of a narcissist right so this is like
i'm wearing a rolex but my spouse is
complaining that the car is falling
apart and i'm like yeah that's fine i
need my rolex that's right because
fixing that car does nothing for my
image out into your reputation yeah
that's right and number four they're
hypocritical most narcissists believes
the rules don't apply to them
even though they're quick to enforce
them on everybody else they may a
narcissistic partner may freely spend on
themselves and regularly join a blow the
budget and they turn around and
criticize you for you bought that shirt
and you're thinking
you just put another car
right and it's this it's it's so
hypocritical and it's often so
disproportional the response to what
actually happened well this is a lack of
integrity right there's no consistency
here right right and the final one is
they are punitive with money and we see
this a lot with narcissists they
weaponize money they use it as a way to
get things i've heard this done
um well we didn't sleep together this
week so no money for you this weekend
or
if you don't do this or this or this
y'all we're not going on vacation right
it's a it's a
tool for punishment um they may plan
something really luxurious for your
birthday let's say the article says here
and then after an argument they're going
to refuse to pay for the expenses
leaving you on the hook because you
signed up you like go ahead and book
those tickets we're going baby and then
you you book the tickets and you get in
a fight like am i paying for those
tickets
and now you've got a mess right so
here's one important um caveat about
this we are real real bad in our culture
george about quarterback um diagnosing
our friends and our loved ones ourselves
um it's the webmd effect or the google
effect you can put any number of of
things like my partner does this this
and this they may have an any number of
of things right any number of diagnosis
i would say don't do that don't do that
if you are wondering if you are trapped
in a relationship with somebody who's
not safe a focus on the behaviors not
the diagnosis if someone makes you feel
unsafe if they're making you feel crazy
if they're gaslighting you all the time
if they put you in a position where you
can't pay for basic necessities
go reach out and call a professional
asap right because you're not safe leave
the diagnosis to the psychiatrist or
psychologist
let's focus on the behavior and if
you're not safe get out of that
situation asap
so as you see these symptoms
it's obviously you have to create some
boundaries and have some really hard
conversations which is not easy with a
narcissist because they're virtually
impossible they're the kings and queens
of spinning things and making you feel
crazy like you talked about with
gaslighting so what is the right way to
approach that if someone's like i think
this person's a narcissist how do i get
them out of my life or keep them at bay
you need to go talk to a professional
counselor you need to go get with a
couple of friends who you trust who
aren't going to be um
yeah yeah not those kind of friends but
ones that you can say hey here's what's
happening in my life am i is this normal
that's the most disconcerting or
heartbreaking thing when you talk to
somebody who's in a relationship with a
true
narcissist
they come to you saying hey can you help
me because i'm not good enough or hey
can you help me because i'm really
struggling um to
be a good wife or a good husband
and you listen to their story and it's
like whoa whoa whoa whoa that's not
normal right and so if you feel like
you are the worst husband ever or the
worst wife ever if you feel like you can
never do anything right or you find
yourself secretly hiding money not
because you're
lack integrity but because you're
trying to make sure the kids have
clothes go talk to a professional
counselor asap
great wisdom there john and good hour
thank you so much and thank you america
for tuning in today it's been a fun show
thank you to all the folks in the booth
keeping the lights on keeping the audio
moving we appreciate you guys this has
been the ramsay show until next time
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you